How can all this even be happening right
now? All this carnage for the What was
it? 400 million Christians being
persecuted, 13 slaughtered every day.
How could this be happening at a time
when the so-called West is so powerful
and is so obsessed with human rights and
equality, you know? You'd think the
West, certainly the so-called Christians
in the West would be doing everything
possible to at least help Christians
throughout the world uh gain equal
rights,
not be persecuted, okay? Not necessarily
have a great life, but just not be
mauled and killed and, you know,
slaughtered. Ah, but remember what both
Eusebius and James of Vitry said. Those
whom Satan cannot reach with a physical
sword, in this case the West, at this
point anyway, that window is closing
very quick, but why? Because the West,
like I told you, after the long vicious
attack on Christendom, which swallowed
up most of it under the guise of Islam,
this final core remained in Europe,
which I call the final bastion of
Christendom, which became a fortress, a
militants fortress of the faith. And it
continued like that for decades,
centuries, okay? And as such, Satan
could not use a sword to kill
Christians. So, he had to subvert them
with his spiritual sword. And this has
been a slow incremental process. It took
It's took decades and decades and
centuries and centuries, okay? But it
has been a very successful, right? This
is why now the West, which was once,
like I said, the bastion of Christendom
and could not at all be touched by the
sword of Satan, the way Christians
throughout the Islamic world can be,
now he has turned his spiritual sword
against them. And he is slaughtering
them in ways that are even more
disturbing and remarkable than the
Christians were being slaughtered
physically by the physical sword. So,
how does he do this? Well, he corrupts
their faith.
He corrupts their knowledge of God,
their knowledge of themselves.
He subverts. He makes demons of people
who will insist to you that they are
Christians, like the majority of the
people who call themselves Christians in
the West. And that is because, if you
are not aware, what is the number one
characteristic of Satan?
He's the father of lies, okay? And he's
also the god of this world.
Little wonder of the West, the
worldliest portion of the world, is
drowning in lies. Okay? And that is what
it's suffering from. First and foremost,
nonstop lies from Satan. That is his
spiritual sword, okay?
Let us count the ways of all the lies
the West buys into, okay? The first one,
of course, is that there is no truth.
Everything is now just whatever you want
it to be.
It's Everything now is subjective. It's
your whatever you think it is. There's
no such thing as gender. There's no men
and women. It's whatever you want it to
be.
Cultures, civilizations, all the same,
right? Multiculturalism, they're all the
same. All lead to the same path.
Islam is just as good, if not better,
obviously, than Christianity.
And history, well, we do with that
whatever we want to do, just so we can
continue the narrative. I can spend a
lot of time talking about these lies,
but
suffice to say, let's just look at all
this gender trans stuff, okay?
Please understand that this talk about
sexual perversion, which is what it is,
there's nothing progressive about it.
It's not nuanced. It's not open-minded.
It's not any of those things, okay? It's
demonic. All right? There's a reason
that these confused people don't want to
be called by singular pronouns like he
or she, and they tell you I'm they,
because they are legion, aren't they?
And if you don't know what I'm talking
about, one when one of the demons that
Christ met and said, "What's your name?"
He said, "We are legion, because they
had many demons inside of them." All
right? And that's what that is. But why
even look so far to the trans stuff? All
of it is so sick. All of it is so
twisted, and none of us even want to see
it or talk about it. Pure homosexuality,
two normal guys hanging out and just,
you know, having sex and adopting babies
is sick, is wrong, is against the truth.
And yet, how many Christians,
self-proclaimed Western Christians, will
even say this? Not many. Why? And now we
come to one of the biggest lies, because
Christians have accepted the biggest
lie, which is that materialism is all
that matters, the physical world, okay?
What is materialism? It's the idea,
which is an atheist idea, that all that
matters is the physical world.
Everything else that we talk about, all
this mumbo jumbo about spirituality,
metaphysics, uh whatever is not real.
Okay, that's the atheist position, fine.
But a lot of Christians will tell you,
"No, I believe in spirituality. I
believe in God. I believe in heaven and
hell, etc., etc." But they are really
materialists, and you can see this in
the way they act, think, and their
actual ethics and mores. So, why, for
example, is homosexuality so fine?
Because, hey, nobody's getting hurt
physically. So, what if their souls are
being torn asunder in ways that
Christians were being physically
persecuted are not suffering from?
That's okay. Why? Well, because
Christians have bought the biggest lie,
that there is nothing beyond the
physical, all right? Despite what they
claim and what they say they believe and
whatever formulaic
uh expression, biblical scriptures they
quote about how they're saved, etc.,
etc. That's just one example.
This I think is the heart of it right
now, which is that Christians have been
so so subverted by the sword, the
spiritual sword of Satan, into buying
into materialism that they've lost sense
of morality, which is much more
important. Guarding morality is much
more important than guarding physical
aspects. Physical doesn't matter. You're
going to die. You're going to get hurt.
I get hurt all the time. I'm going to
die, okay? No biggie. It's going to
happen. It's inevitable. But
the harm that one causes to one's soul
or those of others, that is actual
permanent and eternal.
But we don't even acknowledge that
anymore, because everything's physical,
okay? Love is love. Who's Who's the
judge? Uh all that sort of nonsense has
so permeated Christian mentalities in
the West, because they are one of
Satan's most powerful spiritual swords,
okay? And like I said, this is why Okay,
what does What does Satan do with his
two swords? He persecutes, right? One
physically, one spiritually.
Honestly, the people in the West who are
being persecuted spiritually are
suffering more, I believe, than the
Christians that I described in the
Islamic world and elsewhere, who are
being physically persecuted and killed.
Because those people, yes, they're
physically persecuted, but they actually
have love in their hearts. They have
families. Uh they live normal lives.
They are happy, except for these
outbursts of violence and attacks on
their freedom. But the Christians who
are being subverted and manipulated here
in the West by Satan's spiritual sword
are really miserable people. Uh they
don't have any of that. They think
they're happy because they have wealth,
maybe, and whatever, but um in reality,
they are so miserable. That's why people
in the West have to see psychiatrists
and psychologists, and they have to take
a million different drugs, etc., etc.
And why doing the most normal and basic
thing that people all around the world
can do, like, I don't know, get married
and have children and be normal, is so
hard and so difficult and so
complicated.
That's the second sword of Satan that
nobody sees, and that's the irony. The
fact that you don't see it, you don't
even know you're being struck by it.
That's the whole point of the second
sword of Satan, the spiritual one. You
don't see it. Therefore, you succumb to
it. You think you're doing it. You think
you're the This is what you want. And we
spoke about the two swords of Christ,
and now, of course, you see why they are
needed, aren't they?
Because Satan is
causing havoc with his two swords. He's
causing havoc, as he always has, killing
and slaughtering and persecuting
millions around the world. And he's
causing havoc amongst the spiritually
dead with his spiritual sword, mostly in
the West, who think they're happy, who
think they have everything, because
they're materialists, and they think,
"Oh, look, we have, you know, more
qualitative life. We have more stuff.
Therefore, we're happy." But, of course,
they're more miserable than anyone and
suffering a slow demise, a slow death.
That's why they can't help their
coreligionists who are being physically
persecuted, because they're so
subverted, they cannot even see it that
it's happening to themselves, much less
that it's happening to others. So, what
is the remedy?
Well, it's time to put aside doormat
Christianity. I had to get that phrase
in. That, of course, is one of the
greatest heresies and one of the most
acute [snorts]
aspects of Satan's spiritual sword,
which is convincing Christians in the
West that, "Hey, your religion is
actually easy. You just [snorts] um you
go to a mega church and walk down the
aisle, and you you repeat a verse, and
now you're going to go to heaven, no
matter what you do. Um but and what you
should do is just nothing, because who
are you to judge? And who are you to be
confrontational? And so, you should let
all forms of evil, especially moral
evil,
>> [snorts]
>> get a free pass. Who are you to judge?
And that's doormat Christianity. That is
Satan's favorite friend. And chances are
you are, to one degree or other, a
participant of it. It so permeates
Western society, even non-Western at
this point, that everyone thinks that
this is true Christianity, and nothing
pleases Satan and his minions more than
that idea. So, what's needed? Nothing
less than the two swords of Christ, as
outlined to you, will ever be able to
parry la violence of the two swords of
Satan. Surely, it's time to unsheathe
them both. Bring back the
>> [music]
>> Bring back
the flame.
Bring back
>> [music]
>> the fire
and the
righteousness.